in our series a more perfect union we
aim to show that what unites us as
Americans is certainly far greater than
what divides us this morning we're
focusing on a New York coach it was
using sports to inspire students to go
after their dreams CBS this morning
Saturday caused Michelle Miller shows us
how coach Deborah Thomas's lessons go
far beyond the track Michelle good
morning to you good morning Gail Debra
Thomas had no background in track or a
javelin throwing but now runs a club of
30 students ten are junior Olympian six
are National all-americans 23 are
regional champions five are USA Track
and Field record holders and three are
athletic scholarship winners but the
club has given them much more than just
metal good job Anaya
on the track and field good job baby
coach Debra Thomas is said to wield an
iron fist sighs get your jabs hurry up
run they say I'm straight well guess
what I don't care with a velvet glove
okay you got to work on that they all
know that I got their back they all do
they are in motion the u.s. track and
field Club
Thomas founded seven years ago it offers
options not available in the area like
javelin and discus throwing good I'm
doing javelin and I'm trying to
at only 8 years old Bria Gaspard has
already placed first in competition yeah
she's a great coach and I want to be
doing that check if she wasn't a loser
others on the team a Junior Olympic
champion national champions and u.s.
track and field record holders staff and
fortune got into college on an athletic
scholarship because of the club I get
for that name she's a great coach and a
great person to me and like she's like
another mom to me in a way she conducts
this team like like a big family hence
the name mama Thomas she runs the team
like a family because that's how it
started I'm proud you have no no
background in this no I do not what led
you here I'm telling you my girls my
girls her girls are this mother of nine
five daughters good she started that een
to give them something to do together
kids only do and follow what you show
them if you give them a purpose and you
give them a reason they're gonna go far
after raising two biological children
and her niece and nephew as her own she
became a foster parent I think I was
about four
when Thomas learned that Brianna had
four other sisters one foster child
became five I wanted to her to be happy
and one of the ways I could do that is
to get her sisters back with her she
fell in love with all of us
I don't think it's five girls this a lot
come on guys I really want three feet at
it too this year where do you think you
guys would be right now I think we would
be we would be we wouldn't even be doing
try out would be anything so this year
what are you guys trying to throw in
discus she made an investment in you
guys and now we're trying to tell her
that we're not gonna her down there
we're gonna take her all the way up with
us
some women chamillionaire's she's gonna
be come with us to they're so fun the
club cost about a hundred and fifty
dollars for a student but she makes
adjustments for students who can't
afford it and mama Thomas says she's not
sure when she's going to retire since
she still has so many kids to help but
she already has two grandchildren and
they're already thrown Wow yeah yes
story with all that talent right if that
Club didn't exist does that just go
undiscovered yeah yeah amazing that's
exactly what happened yeah and those
girls might not even all be together you
know they were not they were all
separate back did she coach you know
it's only Stephanie what I heard you did
some track I heard did you do I did not
Beach fact I tried to race these girls
13 are out there 19 21 13 yeah and I
pulled a ligament get there
all right we'll be right back